the last three games the lightning have scored
five or more goals but they've also given up
13 so the Hawks will have to look to expose
them a little bit defensively cuz it hasn't
been that tight for them and right now it's
been a struggle kurish shev Puck tipped in
and a Blackhawks goal from Connor Bard if you
want to see Connor Bard light the lamp come
earliest to the game because he tends to score
the first goal of the game and that was a beauty
it's not always going to be pretty tic-tac-toe
passing but he goes to the net great job a greasy
goal gets great body positioning on Victor
Hedman and puts that one away nice finish by
Bard blocked at Center Ice by Felino
up to Conor Bard for Tyler Johnson
score one almost a two on0 Tyler Johnson's
been robbed in the last two games he does
not miss on this one Beautiful Finish
great execution the Hawks Take the Lead
after going down early in this one watch
Bard he he's he doesn't look where he's
passing he never does non-traditional path
to being among one of the winningest coaches
currently in the NHL two cups and made his
way starting in peeee hockey toino Bard he
scores beauty of a pass by Nick Felino less
than 30 seconds big face off Tampa Bay leaky
defensively and Conor Bard again on his backand
Jones maybe could have taken that one himself
as you know that Tampa Bay PK is going to
shade heavily towards badar to give their
goenda piece of it great Puck Movement by
the Blackhawks and Bard a four-point night
Perry all alone that's his bread and butter
right in his office in front of the blue paint
great execution and the Blackhawks power play
breaks through Conor congratulations a great
team win tonight and individually as well
you had your first multi-point game first
multi-goal game in the NHL four points total
how would you assess your performance tonight
yeah I mean obviously for look at look at our
team I thought um they're they're a team that
that can kind of hem you in your own end a
lot and I thought we really did a good job
in that first 10 minutes kind of just just
sticking with it and and obviously um kind
of bearing down on our chances when they when
they kind of turn it over and um yeah I think
personally felt good and um obviously it's
always nice to to be on the board but uh all
those I think were more so other guys creating
stuff and I was kind of a been a beneficiary